[Music]
a lot of fans of your music they
consider your music to be
sexy time music like that's that's and i
like to call it sexy time
and it's not just me but but you are
known to people say like that's the
music you use to get a woman in the mood
do you hear that from fans well yeah i
mean it all depends on you know what
type of mood you want to put her in
whether it's party or sexy time yeah
you think sexy times was a weird phrase
for me to use
i mean for you yeah
it's sexy time
you must have men come up to you and say
i'm telling you i played this song i
played that song and uh you know what
i've been fortunate to uh make a few
songs that have i guess help guys
through harder moments yeah yeah harder
moments get it but um
but but definitely um have really
enjoyed what i do sure
i don't make love or uh perform to my
own songs intimately
that would be so weird
hey baby it's time to hold on a second
let's check me out
although i often have the television on
in the back
[Laughter]
no one wants to think about that is that
why they're there yeah exactly i have
nine tvs in the room
with me now women obviously they go
crazy when you perform and they can get
very forward i'll say they
it's kind of a classic move for a woman
say maybe throw a bra up on stage but
you've seen them like push the envelope
on this haven't you maybe once or twice
or there's been uh one that i can
definitely remember
um
a young lady decided to just completely
get naked no i didn't let her on the bus
of course no
but what do you mean she got naked where
did she get naked she got the street
literally in the street we were pulling
away from the avengers oh you're done
with the show done with the show and she
we're pulling away from the venue and i
guess she just wanted to show her
dedication so she wanted to show all of
herself
and um we didn't let her on the bus now
who made that decision i was going to
say
that could have been an unpopular
decision on your part other people are
on the bus like maybe maybe she could
come in and we could chat
this way
i know just how mentally ill she is